quand Johnny dit une connerie en
Belgique ça passe pour une phrase
normale c'est du gâchis
[Musique]
et maintenant j'accueille Stéphane
Guillon
[Applaudissements]
alors cette semaine Thierry une fois de
plus le divorce des Sarkozy Monopolis
que font-ils comment vont-ils alors
honneur aux présidents d'après Paris
Match il est au plus mal le désarroi
titre le magazine plusieurs photos nous
alertes Nicolas comptant les pavés de
l'Élysée
Nicolas seul sur un bateau
plus grave Nicolas refuse de s'alimenter
si Enrico Macias ne chante pas à table
[Applaudissements]
une déprime qui inquiète Nicolas ne doit
jamais rester seul sur cette photo
quatre personnes l'entourent pour aller
aux toilettes
plus rien ne l'amuse dimanche il aurait
boudé sa distraction préférée jouer au
ping-pong avec Gilbert Montagné
alors son de cloche totalement différent
de la part de Catherine Nay Nicolas pète
le feu nous dit-elle il va se griser en
retrouvant tous ceux que Cécilia a
écarté Bernard Laporte pour les bonnes
blagues Didier Barbelivien pour les
veillées entre potes Michel Drucker pour
les sorties en vélo personnellement je
préfère encore compter les pavés
[Applaudissements]
le président ne pense qu'à s'amuser
mardi soir il a éteint toutes les
lumières de l'Elysée pour un cache-cache
géant
il était question d'un shabbit mais
sans Pascal Sevran c'est moins drôle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas un seul mot d'ordre
distraire le président pour cette raison
Johnny renonce à la nationalité belge
quand Johnny dit une connerie en
Belgique ça passe pour une phrase
normale c'est du gâchis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et Cécilia comment va-t-elle bien nous
dit match elle affronte sa nouvelle vie
avec détermination et courage attention
voici des images très dures le courage
Cécilia sort de chez Franck et fils
Ralph Lauren Barbara buis Versace etc 8
heures de shopping non-stop dans l'Est
Républicain elle annonçait la couleur on
ne m'empêchera pas de soulager la misère
du monde
[Applaudissements]
pour les fiançailles de sa fille Cécilia
s'est surpassé bien choisir éviter les
fautes de goût tout un art chez une
femme qui a enterré son ex-mari en
Afflelou mais divorcé en Ray-Ban
devenir un citoyen lambda oublié les
dorures Élysées une lutte quotidienne
désormais nous dit match Cécilia conduit
son hostile mini elle-même cela dit une
Austin Mini avec chauffeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai alors une nouvelle vie ce
sont aussi des résolutions Cécilia
promet de vivre discrètement et dans
l'ombre paroles tenue sur toutes les
couvertures réalisées cette semaine
Cécilia à bord des couleurs sombres
automales automnales pardon toute la
discrétion d'une femme qui a choisi
l'ombre ici l'ombre
[Applaudissements]
et voici en exclusivité la photo la plus
discrète de Cecilia elle dort dans sa
chambre
Nicolas quant à lui ne se consolera pas
dans une carrière de mannequin fonction
oblige dommage lui seul osé marié la
chemise Lacoste et le bermudas à fleurs
voilà pour toutes infos supplémentaires
concernant Cécilia et Nicolas n'hésitez
pas contactez Isabelle Balkany on a tous
une vieille copine qui ne baisse plus
mais qui sait tout sur tout à la semaine
prochaine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu